every 37 seconds according to the FBI
statistics of 2023
sorry 2024
in July 31st it says more than 145,000
rapes took place again you multiply that
it comes to 32 seconds every 32 seconds
one rape is taking place you know I'm
giving this lecture since the last about
2 hours about 2 and a 2 hours 10 minutes
so in 2 hours more than 2 hours already
more than 120 rapes may have taken place
since the time I'm giving this talk more
than 120 rapes may have taken place in
in USA
in Islamic Sharia
if you rape a woman I'm if you rape a
woman you get death penalty
death penalty
the Islamic system wear hijab. A man if
he looks at a woman lower his gaze woman
wears hijab. After that if a man rapes a
woman capital punishment death penalty
non-Muslims say oh death penalty in this
age OF SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY ISLAM IS A
BARBARIC RELIGION AND WHEN I ASK them
the question hypothetically suppose
someone rapes your mother and if the
rapist in brought in front of you what
punishment will you give to the rapist
believe me 100% all of them said we will
give him death penalty some went to the
extent of same we will torture him to
death so if someone rapes your mother
you want to give Death penalty. Somebody
raped somebody else's mother, you said
death penalty, barbaric law. Why these
double standards? I'm asking you the
question that if you implement the
Sharia,
the Islamic law in USA today that any
man looks at a woman, he should lower
his gaze. After that, the woman wears
Islamic hijab, complete body covered.
The only part that can be seen are the
face and hands up to the wrist. And
after this, any man rapes a woman,
capital punishment, death penalty. I'm
asking you the question will the rate of
rape in USA will it increase? Will it
remain the same or will it decrease?
It will increase it will remain the same
or it will decrease
decrease. Simple answer. You don't get
award for that. You implement the Sharia
you get results. So that the reason
Islam by doing hijab uplifts the women.
It is the western talk of women's
liberalization.
which is nothing but a disguised form of
exploitation of a body, deprivation of
honor, degradation of a soul. The
western society when it talks about
women's right, women's liberalization,
they are nothing but changing the status
of a woman to that of a concubine
to that of a mistress to that of a
society butterfly which are mere tools
in the hands of pleasure seekers and sex
marketeers which are hidden behind the
colorful screen of art and culture. in
the name of art and culture they are
degrading our mothers degrading our
wives degrading our sisters you know
when you have the advertisement I was
told that there was advertisement of BMW
you know BMW it's supposed to be for the
youngsters a very fast car you know fast
car competition with Mercedes I was told
there was an advertisement of BMW
and in the advertisement there was a
girl standing standing in front of the
car. A young girl standing with bikini
in front of the car and the ad read test
drive her now. Who the girl or the car?
Now who drives cars more? Men.
They are selling our daughters, selling
our wives, selling our mothers. You see
an ad of a motorcycle. Now how many
women ride motorcycles? Men ride. So
what they do with a with a motorcycle?
You have a woman. What is the woman
doing in the ad for what? Attracting. So
in the name of woman's right, what are
they doing? They're selling your
daughters. They're selling your mothers.
They're selling your wives. So be
careful of this trick of the western
civilization. Islam protects the woman,
has uplifted the woman and shows you a
way how to maintain the status of the
woman.